You won the Emmy this year. What was that-
What was that like? Tell me,
cause I've never won one.
You haven't? Well, you should have.
It's just. I don't know.
Surely you've been nominated.
I have been, I'm a perennial bridesmaid.
Did you get sucked into the game
when you were nominated?
As Tom Hanks calls it, the trophy run.
This is my favorite. He
said that with no irony.
He said, "Yeah, I know it's, you know,
around the holidays, usually it's kind of
involved in the trophy run, so."
And I thought, wow, that is the greatest.
Ah that's great.
The trophy run.
And he has been many times.
And he has been. And
it's like Ty Cobb said,
"It ain't bragging if you've done it."
And he'd done it many
times. What was it like?
How, did you think you were going to win?
No, I honestly didn't and I felt like
I was getting set up because, you know,
my agent kept sending me things, you know,
pieces that said I was going to win.
And, and I thought, Nope, I've seen this.
I won't name names, but
I've seen this happen
to too many people where they're
set up, you know? And I kept thinking it
for your consideration of the movie.
So no by the time,
it was going to be announced.
I had convinced myself,
no, I wasn't going to.
And I wanted the show to win.
I thought that would be so
great for Eugene and Daniel.
I really did want the show to win,
but I did not honest
to God didn't expect it
and was so happy to be with everyone.
You know, we, I think Daniel talked Eugene
into having something. And so it was
going to be a barbecue
in Eugene's backyard.
Then there was the whole COVID thing.
And then they had, I
think 50 people invited
two days before and they moved it
to where we were Castle Loma in Toronto.
It was kind of an event
place as old castle.
And then two days before the Emmys
or before the party, the
Ontario premier changed the law
so that it was maximum 25 people outdoors,
maximum 10 indoors. They had
to un invite or disinvite
half the people. And there were
all people who'd been
nominated for the show.
And of course everybody we
wanted to see and be with.
So that part was sad,
but then we got there
and then I looked at our world dressed
up and we got, I thought, how are we,
how do we have stylists for a Zoom thing?
What are we doing?
Well you could wear. You could be naked
from the waist down. Nobody would know.
Well, apparently you do find out.
That's right.
Oh dear. What was he thinking?
Yeah. So we got all dressed up.
And when I got there, I thought, Oh
this looks like we think
we're going to win.
This is almost too pretty
and too fancy and too lovely.
And we had this lovely
dinner party and they had two
producers and a big screen
and you could see the other
nominees. And, and they said, okay.
And we all got tested of course.
We're safe to be with each other,
but we wore masks. And
they said, but if you win,
you're going to go up to
a microphone. Oh, come on.
That looks like we think
we're going to win.
Can we just stay in our seats if win?
And I'm not thinking
we're going to. He said,
"Well everyone else is going
to go to the microphone."
Okay. So then I look
like I can't walk. Okay.
So I have to go if I,
if I do, but I won't.
Okay. And they say, okay,
we're about to start.
And your category is the first one up.
Just because it makes
you feel kind of sickly,
but then Jimmy Kimmel and
Jennifer Aniston did that
ridiculous bit with the fire,
burning out the card and not
for a second was I thinking,
Oh hurry. Get to it. I was just laughing.
You know, at their silly bit.
She kept, she was so good
with the extinguisher.
Just yeah. Better go at it again.
Yeah. This looks bad.
And then he read my name
and I have that card now,
Jimmy Kimmel sent it to me, so great.
Half burned away, but my
name is still in there.
Yeah. And then, sorry,
I've gone on way too long,
but, and then Eugene won and
then Daniel won for writing.
And then it got to Annie
and she's sitting beside me.
And I said, it was about
to announce her category.
I said, "Now you have to win. Sorry."
"You actually have to win now."
Now you have to. And she said to me,
"Who do I apologize to first?"
It was insane.